>> VOTERS IN SAN FRANCISCO SENT
A BIG MESSAGE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
THEY RULED D.A. BOUDIN AFTER HIS
APPROACH ON CRIME WAS TOO
LENIENT ON CRIMINALS.
BOUDIN IS BLAMING THE RIGHT FOR
HIS LOSS.
>> PEOPLE ARE ANGRY.
THEY'RE FRUSTRATED.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED TONIGHT.
THE RIGHT WING BILLIONAIRESOUT
SPENT US THREE TO 1.
THEY EXPLOITED AN ENVIRONMENT IN
WHICH PEOPLE ARE APPROPRIATELY
UPSET.
THEY CREATED A DYNAMIC THAT WE
WERE SHADOWBOXING.
>> SOUNDS LIKE A BUNCH OF
EXECUTIONS.
THE RESULT, THE PEOPLE'S VOICES
WERE HEARD AND SENT A CLEAR
MESSAGE THAT EVEN THE MOST
LEFT-LEANING CITIES ARE FED UP
WITH SURGING CRIME RATES.
LOS ANGELES, GEORGE GASCON COULD
SUFFER A SIMILAR FATE.
HE'S RECENTLY BEEN UNDER FIRE
FOR ISSUING A VERY LIGHT
SENTENCE OVER A TEEN DRIVER'S
HIT-AND-RUN.
PUBLIC SAFETY IS EVERYTHING.
I MEAN, IF YOU TALK TO ANY
FAMILY, ANY MOM OR DAD OR
TEACHER, ANYONE IN ANY COMMUNITY
REGARDLESS OF A DIVVISIVENESS
AND POLITICS, RACE, RELIGION,
EVERYONE WANTS TO KNOW THAT THEY
CAN BE SAFE.
THEIR CHILDREN CAN BE SAFE GOING
TO SCHOOL, THEY CAN WALK DOWN
THE STREET IN PEACE AND I THINK
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS D.A. IS
JUST COMPLETELY LOST.
I SERVED ON THE HONOLULU CITY
COUNCIL YEARS AGO.
MY DISTRICT ON THE HONOLULU CITY
COUNT
CI
COUNCIL, 100,000 PEOPLE.
SAME SIZE OF MAYOR PETE'S CITY
OF SOUTH BEND, INDIANA.
I WAS CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PUBLIC SAFETY,
POLICE, FIRE, LIFEGUARDS AND
UNDERSTANDING THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THEORETICAL.
WHEN YOU HAVE HOMELESS
ENCAMMENTS ON SIDEWALKS,
ELDERLY, DISABLED, CHILDREN
BEING PUSHED OUT IN BUSY STREETS
TO WALK DOWN THE STREETS, THOSE
ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE
CAN TAKE ACTION ON AND BRING A
CHANGE TO CLEAR THE SIDEWALKS
AND MAKE SURE THE COMMUNITY IS
SAFE.
THERE'S SO MANY EXAMPLES.
FOR IN D.A. TO BE SO OUT OF
TOUCH IS MIND-BLOWING TO ME.
DANA, I'LL START WITH YOU.
HIS RESPONSE FROM THAT CLIP
BLAMING RIGHT-WING BILLIONAIRES
AND LATER HE BLAMED THE POLICE.
>> Dana: IF BOUDIN WANTS TO FEEL
BETTER ABOUT HIM, HE SHOULD
LISTEN TO NPR.
THE REPORTER GAVE HIM EVERY
EXCUSE.
IT WAS IF PANDEMIC.
HE DIDN'T CHANGE ANY POLICIES
THE PREVIOUS PERSON HAD IN.
THE PEOPLE WERE NOT THAT UPSET
ABOUT THE QUALITY OF LIFE.
IT'S BEEN EXAGGERATED BY
EVERYONE.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE THIS PIECE.
NATIONAL PUBLIC RADIO.
ONE OF THE DEMOCRATS THAT LOOKS
AT ALL OF THESE THINGS FROM THE
GROUP, THEY SAID THE DEMOCRATS
ON THE FAR LEFT DO NOT SEE THIS
AS A WAKE-UP CALL, THEY'RE
LOOKING AT A PERMANENT MINORITY
STATUS.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT IF YOU
LOOK AT WHO VOTED FOR BOUDIN, IT
WAS VERY SIMILAR TO WHO VOTED
FOR THAT WOMAN THAT I CAN'T
REMEMBER HER NAME.
SHE RAN AGAINST ERIC ADAMS.
THE MUCH MORE FAR LEFT
PROGRESSIVE HERE IN NEW YORK
CITY.
MAYA WILEY.
THANK YOU.
ULTRA RICH NEIGHBORHOOD, THE
WHITE LIBERAL NEIGHBORHOODS,
THEY VOTED FOR HER AND THEY'RE
THE ONES THAT VOTED FOR HIM.
LOOK AT WHO VOTED TO RECALL
BOUDIN.
THERE'S THE ONE NEIGHBORHOOD.
THE REST IS BLUE.
>> THIS IS INTERESTING.
THIS IS YOUR HOME TERRITORY.
HOW DOES IT GET TO THIS POINT?
GO AHEAD.
>> Greg: A, YOU ONLY HAVE SO
MUCH SHELF SPACE.
>> I TALK ABOUT THIS.
I'M OKAY WITH TACKLE PROGRESS
NOUNS AND TALKING ABOUT STATUES
AND THE OFFENSIVENESS OF HOLIDAY
DECORATIONS.
FIRST, GET THE BASIC STUFF DOWN.
WHAT HAPPENED IS THEY REPLACED
THE BASIC CONCERNS WITH THESE
EXTERNAL NONSENSE.
SO WHAT HAPPENED IS THEY ALSO
REPLACED THE REAL VICTIMS,
VICTIMS OF RAPE, MURDER, FAMILY
SUFFERING.
WHATEVER -- ANY CRIME WAS
REPLACED WITH THESE POLITICAL
IDENTITY VICTIMS OF TIK TOK
POLITICS.
THE PEOPLE THAT CLAIM THEIR
FEELINGS ARE -- THAT'S WHAT THEY
CHASED.
THAT WAS PROBABLY THE BIG
PROBLEM.
THE OTHER THING, I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANYTHING MORE DANGEROUS
TO A MINORITY POPULATION THAN A
WHITE LEFTIST.
THEY CAN EXPERIMENT WITH THEM.
THEY CAN TRY OUT THINGS AND BE
IMMUNE FROM THE CONSEQUENCES.
THEY LIVE IN THE BETTER
NEIGHBORHOODS.
SO THEY CAN SAY LET'S RELEASE
THE CRIMINALS.
IT'S NOT MY PROBLEM.
I'M NOT MUGGED.
I FEEL SO GOOD.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY, I LIKE THIS
RECALL VOTE IDEA.
WHY DON'T THEY JUST MAKE IT
AUTOMATIC EVERY SIX MONTHS.
THAT WAY YOU CAN -- REMEMBER,
THIS IS A STORY OF REALITY
VERSUS IDEOLOGY.
REALITY WON.
LOOK HOW LONG IT TOOK.
THREE YEARS SINCE 2019.
IF YOU HAD AN AUTOMATED RECALL
VOTE EVERY SIX MONTHS, THEY
WOULD HAVE STOPPED THIS THING
WELL AHEAD AND LIVES WOULD HAVE
BEEN SAVED.
>> I MEAN, SPEAKING OF REALITY
VERSUS FANTASY IN THIS AGE OF
WORDS OR VIOLENCE, JUDGE, YOU
SPENT YOUR ENTIRE CAREER
FIGHTING FOR VICTIMS OF CRIME TO
SEE A DISTRICT ATTORNEY WHOSE
SOLE RESPONSIBILITY OF PUBLIC
SAFETY ACTING THE WAY HE HAS TO
MAKE YOUR BLOOD BOIL.
>> Jeanine: IT DOES.
THE TRUTH IS THE JOB OF A
PROSECUTOR, AN ELECTED DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IS TO ENFORCE THE RAW.
IT'S NOT TO WORRY ABOUT THE
DEFENDANT.
THAT'S THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY'S
JOB AND THE JUDGE'S JOB.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW I BELIEVE
AND I PRAY THAT WE'RE SEEING THE
END OF PROGRESSIISM AS IT
RELATES TO THE LEFT.
THE LEFT BOUGHT INTO THIS AFTER
GEORGE FLOYD.
THEY BROUGHT IN THAT THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
BROKEN AND WE'RE GOING TO FIX
IT.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE EQUAL
JUSTICE.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE EQUITY, FAIR
CASH BAIL AND ALL OF THAT STUFF.
THE TRUTH IS THE SYSTEM WASN'T
BROKEN.
DEREK CHAUVIN THAT KILLED GEORGE
FLOYD WAS CONVICTED OF MURDER.
HE WILL BE IN PRISON THE REST OF
HIS LIFE.
NOW WHAT THEY'RE SEEING IS THAT
WHAT WE'VE DONE, WEE HAVE
CREATED A SEN NARROW  --
SCENARIO WHERE THE BAD GUYS
DON'T TAKE POLICING SERIOUSLY.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS ENCOURAGING
PEACEFUL PROTESTS, BUT THEY'RE
NOT ENFORCING THE LAW.
THEN WHAT THEY'RE LEFT WITH IS A
NONSAFE ENVIRONMENT IN FRONT OF
A SECURITY JUSTICE' HOME.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
THERE'S ALL TALK AND NO ACTION.
>> THAT'S WHERE JESSE, THEY'RE
CLEARLY OUT OF TOUCH.
ONE OF MANY EXAMPLES.
THEY CAN TAKE A LESSON FROM YOUR
BOOK AND GET OUT ON THE STREET
AND GO TALK TO PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: WOW!
EVER HAVE PEOPLE OVER FOR A
DINNER PARTY AND THEY WANT TO
CHANGE EVERYTHING ABOUT YOUR
MENU?
THEY GET IN THE KITCHEN.
THEY START ADDING THINGS TO THE
DISHES THAT YOU DON'T WANT TO
DO.
LIKE YOU HAVE A LASAGNE.
WHY DON'T WE FRY IT?
NO.
YOU BAKE A LASAGNE.
LET'S HAVE WHITE WINE.
NO.
WE'RE SERVING RED WINES.
THAT'S WHAT LIBERALS.
THEY WANT TO EXPERIMENT AND TRY
OUT NEW STUFF AFTER 25 YEARS OF
LOW CRIME RATES.
IT'S NONSENSICAL.
THEY COME IN AND SAY PUTTING IN
LOTS OF PEOPLE IN PRISON.
IT'S WORKING.
LET'S TRY SOMETHING ELSE.
LET'S EMPTY THE PRISONS AND NOT
PROSECUTE EVERYBODY.
SO ALL HELL BREAKS LOOSE AND
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WHITE
GUILT TAKES OVER.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT HAVE WHITE
GUILT.
THEY GET IN CHARGE, THEY GET
CONTROL OF THINGS AND THEN THEY
TRY TO ASSUAGE THE WHITE GUILT.
IT HURTS MORE MINORITIES THAN
ANYBODY.
THE PEOPLE IN THE WHITE GUILT
PARADISE ARE IMMUNE.
IT'S A BIG WARNING SHOT.
FIRST IT'S THE SCHOOL BOARD
KNUCKLE HEADS AND THE RADICAL
D.A.
THE LEFT IS PANICKED IN WHAT
THEY'RE SEEING IN SAN FRANCISCO.
>> Greg: DON'T COUNT OUT
STUPIDITY.
IT'S NOT JUST WHITE GUILT.
IT'S A LOT OF STUPIDITY.
>> Jesse: IT'S BOTH.
>> Jeanine: IT'S PEOPLE BUYING
IN TO WORDS.
WITHOU